[Music]  [Music]  uh  [Music]  i do them  help me  help you can't do this today  the birth is over  thank you for your participation  the annual purge will conclude in three  two one  thank you for your participation  we survived all police and emergency  services have been reinstated  all crime including murder is now  illegal  come on let's get to work  one night only rest of the year is  peaceful  [Music]  help me help me  the purge is over please  no it ain't this is insane  nobody hear the sirens there's no crime  anymore  anything else you rich can't hide behind  your steel walls no more  powerless how does that feel it's the  real purge the forever purge  hurry up they're coming  come on follow me there's nowhere safe  to go  no way to get help oh my god  we gotta find another way to get out of  [Music]  here  this country's gonna collapse  mexico is opening its borders for the  next six hours let's go  we're in this together  [Music]  does this translate  [Music]  foreign